the jurgen experience the 80s
and the 50s were the worst time for
movies ever because it was just this
kind of politically correct time now in
the 50s it was different because that
was just
was society what is that in the 80s it
was self
it was uh self-censorship was going on
what started that well it was just the
the rise of political
correctness after the 70s where
everything was just
go as far as you can then all of a
sudden uh
everything got watered down uh in the
70s you had movies where it's like
characters weren't necessarily the hero
they were [ __ ] up but they were
interesting characters and you sat down
and you followed them whether it be
travis bickle or
charlie raine and rolling thunder or joe
peter boyle's character and joe they
weren't the heroes
but you could even have heroes and they
could die meaninglessly at the end
that was actually considered a
commercial uh a commercial ending back
in the 70s because it just shows how uh
you can't win everything's [ __ ] you
just can't win in america it's just the
way it is
you go and you fight in vietnam you
survive vietnam and you get shot in a
liquor store
during a hold up um everything was
cynical
then all of a sudden in the 80s all that
was washed away and the most important
thing
about a character was that they were
likeable and that was the
every character had to be likable and
the audience had to like everybody
and even a movie that pushed the
envelope and tried to do
chancy things well it could do it for
about an hour
then the last 20 minutes would be them
literally
going back on everything they did the
first hour apologizing it and you know
making everything
fine i'll give you a good example of
that okay it's just like
okay the critics always really preferred
bill murray movies to chevy chase movies
however it does seem as if the point of
all the bill murray movies
is that he's this kind of hip cool
curmudgeon
smart ass guy who in the last
20 minutes gets a transformation
and becomes this nice guy yeah and we're
and and almost apologizes for who he was
the entire movie before the whole rest
of the movie before
uh before that happens groundhog day
stripes stripes
groundhog day scrooge you know the whole
thing i mean when
like like for instance stripes how does
he go from where
warren oates kick his kicks his ass
deservedly kicks his ass he deserves to
get
belly punched by warren oates in that
movie how does he go from being this
iconoclastic
i don't give a [ __ ] about anything i get
beat up by warren oates and now he's
rallying the troops and now he's getting
there
he's you know he's getting their army on
during the the parade
and now he's like leading a secret
mission
the same thing with like with like with
groundhog day i mean does anybody really
think a less sarcastic
bill murray is a better bill murray i
mean maybe it's better for andy mcdowell
but not for us as the
as the viewer yet yet
chevy chase movies don't play that [ __ ]
chevy chase is the same super silliest
[ __ ]
at the end of the movie that he is at
the beginning
he never changes in his stuff he's
always like
a bit of a dick and is always completely
sarcastic i mean unless they cast on
playing a dope like he is in the
uh the vacation movies but when he's
playing like a chevy character
he's uh you know he never apologizes for
who he is
stays that way throughout the whole film
and even if there is a a slight change
that's not the whole point of the movie
yeah it's like turning him into a nice
cuddly guy
have you ever worked with him nah i
would i'd love to
i'm a gigantic fan of his early work
like the fletch stuff
yeah yeah yeah yeah i just think in
saturn live and sometimes oh the whole
first season of saturn like
pretty much all those early movies
except for oh heavenly dog all those
early movies
he seems today to be this like really
uncomfortable person
he seemed it's almost like i it like too
many people
paid attention to him for too long and
it freaked him out like i don't know
them yeah but when i
see you know stories about them or
interviews with them or
you know any any weird controversy that
happens with them i'm almost like i
think the guy just got overwhelmed
yeah and now he's just like get the [ __ ]
away from me you know like everything is
get the [ __ ] away from me
yeah yeah yeah exactly i'm a big fan of
his
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely
free you don't have to have a premium
account to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience